the Ellen Powell versus kleiner perkins
trial captured the fascination of the
country highlighting this issue of
gender discrimination in Silicon Valley
the jury found in favor of kleiner
perkins but what did you see in that
trial I thought it was so interesting
about the trial is that so many women
not just in technology but across
industries saw their own experiences
there and you saw that you saw women
posting did you sure I mean I wrote a
whole book about it experiences this but
what's happening is that we have
systematic stereotypes of women and
systemic biases of women that for men
likeability and success is correlated as
they get more successful more powerful
they're better liked for women success
and likability are negatively correlated
as a woman gets more successful more
powerful she is less liked a lot of the
things that Ellen Pao alleged were small
she was asked to take notes at a meeting
she wasn't in a tree when taking notes
she wasn't invited to a dinner an
all-male dinner a lot of these things
are incremental small things that don't
seem like a big deal but taken together
maybe they are how do you prevent it was
one interesting thing that came out of
the dinner we had in is how some women
said that they're not invited for
instance to go on business trips because
of the American law which is you know
with the men are worried about sexual
harassment law so suddenly it's all the
men going on the business trips and the
women are for the women are left behind
but it you know if I just get one
radical suggestion and and and because I
don't actually think we're going to get
to a situation where boardrooms have
equal women for another hundred years
even if we have these the way to get
there is to do what Scandinavia's done
and
I know a lot of women don't agree with
this but I just think you've got to say
any new company that sets up from today
must have at least 50% women on the
board the irony of the Ellen Pao trial
is that kleiner perkins actually has top
women partners and most of the top
venture capital firms in Silicon Valley
don't at all so I wonder if the Silicon
Valley have a different problem or a
worse gender problem than other parts of
the world then the rest of the world
I think Silicon Valley has one
particular problem which is the pipeline
of engineers for women is dwindling so
in 1985 women were 35% of computer
science majors in the United States
where 18% today so that is a uniquely
Silicon Valley problem but if you look
at the leadership ranks there is not an
industry out there no matter how many of
its workers are women that has enough
women in leadership the nonprofit
industry in the United States 75% of the
workers are women so many women run
their big nonprofits 21% even with 75%
of the workers and so our biases against
women as leaders need to be exposed
understood and changed during that trial
a lot of things bubble up twitter was
slapped with a gender discrimination
lawsuit Facebook is being sued by a
former female employee who says that she
was harassed at work her boss said
something like why don't you just go
home and take care of your kids this is
your issue I'm sure this concerns you
Cheryl well we put out a statement on
that on that case which is we think
there was the shows that she was treated
fairly but let's leave that case aside
because these cases happened the
treatment of women in the workforce is
an issue we all have it the assumptions
that men can have both families and
women and work and women can't those are
bad and those are hard and we need to
change this women bosses are not always
the best at treating women well